MYLES WARD: Hi, everybody.
My name is Myles Ward.
I'm the global head of solutions
for Google's Cloud platform.
And I'm super excited
to present to you today
about a topic that's very
near and dear to my heart.
I've been operating
application infrastructure
for over a decade
today, built a startup
and operated its systems.
And I've worked through
hundreds of businesses
as they translate
their infrastructure
and their operations from
a private environment
or from other facilities
into public cloud.
So what I'm hoping
to do is walk you
through in a relatively
informal way.
I'm going to talk as plainly
as I can about what I've
seen work, what I've
seen be functional,
what kinds of gotchas
there are as you
come onto Google Cloud, what
sorts of things to expect,
so that we can create
an opportunity for you
to be able to capture as
much value as possible
from our infrastructure.
And to start with that
I'm going to need to ask
the developers to get out.
Anybody a developer in the room?
Hardcore developers?
Good.
They're all in
the other meetings
talking about
rewriting everything.
Leave them that
part of the work.
I like software development.
I think it's an
interesting challenge.
It's nowhere near as fun
as keeping things alive,
delivering value over time.
Building the first
time is frankly kind
of the sort of fun part, right?
This is the real
working part where
we're building a system that
can survive the test of users,
the test of data,
and the test of time.
So I expect that for
many of you this new move
to cloud, the concept of public
cloud as an infrastructure
creates a bunch of
new opportunity.
And I can tell you that the
future is very bright there,
and it also potentially
presents some challenges.
And I want to talk
through those challenges
and make sure that we're
being as clear as we can
around what you can expect
as you come to public cloud.
So as I understand it-- and as
I'm talking to customers every
day--
what I see in
practice is a system
that's born out of the
history of technology
in practice at every
business, everywhere.
So maybe you rent a chunk
of a collocation facility,
or you've got a
data center or two.
You have redundancy and
availability provided
by more than one virtual
machine or maybe more than one
physical host--
but not 3s or 10s or 20s.
You have applications that
are installed often manually.
Sometimes you've
got some automation
that's been built
in there that's
managing the way that
applications get deployed,
either in virtual environments
or in bare metal environments.
And then you've also got a bunch
of weird stuff tucked around
under the corners.
You got a desktop
under the water cooler.
You got a machine that sits
underneath Billy's back
build box that's where all
the really fun stuff happens.
Like the complexity
of these systems
is born out of their
creative construction
as they're built over time.
You probably have at
least one or two Hadoops.
I'll tell you a funny bit.
My start up, we experimented
with Hadoop when it was 0.0001.
And we went to a conference
and we were calling it Heydoop
for like three months,
because we had no idea how
it is that you talk about that.
It's a clear item.
Listen for anybody who
mispronounces the names of very
complicated technical products.
It means they learned
about it by reading.
You want those
people on your team.
They read the docs.
So we also are seeing
lots of businesses
use a whole panoply of
different storage systems.
I think some of the
highest complexity
sits in filers and databases
of a zillion varieties
and the application connectivity
between those databases.
That can be some
of the stuff that's
some of the most complicated
in non-dynamic public cloud
environments.
And I think most of the assembly
of these kinds of systems,
again, is happening at
the same pace as business.
You have a quarterly
set of goals.
You have a relatively
short planning window.
You have a view to where
it is that your business is
trying to go for
a specific product
launch or a specific
regional launch,
or just trying to be able
to do the next update
of physical infrastructure.
And that means
that because you're
making this sort of relatively
short planning horizon
you take locally
optimal choices.
You say, well, if we
need one more box,
let's buy one more box.
Instead of taking a minute
to step back and look
at the overall systems and be
able to evaluate for what's
most efficient in writ large.
Our environment-- we hear
from customers quite a lot--
is that there's this
very big opportunity
in the middle of a movement,
in the middle of a transition
from one kind of
technology to another
to clean up some of the
bad choices of the past.
We see people try to use it
as an investment in reduction
in technical data
or operations data.
Try to take the
opportunity-- when
we do that cloud thing
we're going to do it right.
We're going to get
serious about automation.
We're going to get knee deep
into this whole new world
of stuff and make sure that
everything works properly.
And that movement opportunity is
one that frankly flies totally
in the face of all of the ITIL
best practices that you've
been told that says, change
just one thing at a time,
move all the stuff,
don't screw with it,
make sure that it
works in that way,
and then start removing
individual building blocks
and pieces.
So we want to help
you think through
which are the kinds of places
where a little bit of change
as you move makes sense,
will reduce your risk,
will make it so that these
systems operate more reliably,
and which changes maybe
you should hold off on.
Make it so that you move
in a way that's easier
to digest and understand.
So we hear all the time
that-- oh, man, oh, man.
Once this sort of magical
mystical system in the Cloud
take over everything,
operations will
be so incredibly easy that we
will never have to do anything.
The server list thing
just means that there
are no operators in the world.
I will give you a hint, and I
don't even have to make it up.
It's great.
I get to quote the
chairman of Google.
And he says, "The number
one limiting resource
for businesses is our
technical skills."
Right?
He just said it onstage
like 20 minutes ago.
You are all the technical
people that he's talking about.
None of your businesses are in a
situation where all of a sudden
they find themselves with
this incredible opportunity
to get rid of their best,
brightest, and most talented
people in order
to save $1 or $2.
In reality, most
companies are dying
to find more talented,
aggressive, innovative folks.
And I can think of
no better way for you
to give evidence that you are
in that category of operators
than by taking on the
challenge of this more
complicated and more
technically challenging
move to public cloud.
That can kind of sound like
sort of a crappy sales pitch,
but I also watch it happen.
I go into companies, and
over the course of months
a couple of their folks
stand up and say, I've
got to figure out
how this thing works.
And somebody gets
up, I can see him
in the console clacking
away at things.
And then a couple
of months later
that person's performance
is seen as great.
And I see new job titles on
business cards and everything
starts to move in a way that
I think most employees want.
So I also want to make
sure that you recognize
we are on the hook with you.
It's super easy to be able
to quote the chairman.
It makes my job really nice.
He listed this whole
litany of teams at Google
that are committed to
our customer's success.
That's the engineers
on the Google side
that are here to help you.
And I'll restate the
list, because I think it's
super useful to understand.
We have at the very
beginning of your interaction
with us, customer engineers.
Those are folks that
are dedicated resources
for working with our customers
to ensure that you understand
our platform, that you know what
building blocks are available,
that you have access
to all of our resources
for on-boarding education.
And as you have clear
questions about how
our systems are built, they're
the first point of contact.
As they want and you want a
little executive air cover.
You have a boss or their
boss or somebody is saying,
I don't about this
public cloud thing.
That seems kind of--
we have folks for that.
That's called the
Office of the CTO.
So if you want to interact
with folks from us that
were CTOs or CIOs
at other businesses
that have been there and
done this transition before,
we have full time
Google employees that
will come help you with that.
If both of those folks say
the problem is not the bosses,
the problem is
that they're trying
to do something that's
particularly unique,
and they have a pattern that
we haven't heard of before--
that's my team,
solutions architecture.
We'll come help ensure
that what you're designing
is best practice.
Ensuring that the
operations patterns
that you want to follow meet
the needs of your customers.
And making sure that
that's something
that gets documented,
so that you can reuse
those patterns over and over.
Everything that's at
cloud.google.com/solutions is
an output of that work effort.
We've also got folks in
professional services that
can augment your
staff as you build up
for a big transition
or migration.
We have folks in
customer engineering--
it's called customer
reliability engineering-- that
will sit with you
years after you
launch to ensure that your
operations practices follow
the Google SRE model, follow the
model for high scale web facing
operations.
So we are recommending
some changes,
and those changes are
born out of the fact
that this model is
way more efficient.
So I have seen now 30
different spreadsheets
from 30 different
companies just this year
describing to me what
their actual cost
of their private
environments are.
I will give you a hint--
none of those have
the same line items.
Nobody has the same list.
There's not some
sort of central place
where all the actual
costs get written down.
And most of the
time this stuff is
done by departments
where they inherit
some of the basic
infrastructure from other parts
of the business.
That's very powerful if
what your business unit only
has to pay for is maybe the
new computers or the SAS
applications that
you want to deploy.
But for what we're watching,
those externalities
can be very real constraints
in your ability to be nimble.
So I work with companies all
the time that grow, grow, grow,
grow until they have
filled up that data center,
and now they need another one.
And that next one
computer costs a whole lot
more than the last one.
And so that independence
from scale--
does not matter if
you want a couple
of pieces or a whole
bunch of pieces--
allows you to stop thinking
about the power and the cooling
and all of the rest of the
infrastructural building
blocks.
How many folks have
screwed around for hours
with routing tables in the core
routing of your data center?
Folks done that?
Yes?
Sucks.
Super sucky.
Right?
And then you're in the middle
of trying to figure out,
how do I redo addressing?
And what's the number
range we're going to use?
And, oh, does that overlap
with these other guys?
You delete all that stuff.
We have a petabyte a second
bi-sectional bandwidth
already installed.
At any point you need a little
more network it's already here.
You want the network for
another 400 machines?
That's great.
It's already installed.
So that all of the
work associated
with that instrumentation moves
up a layer of abstraction.
And that's the change
that we're recommending.
Rather than you logging
into the individual switch
and making sure that it's
configured in the way
that you want, or
altering the firewall
on this individual
firewall box, you
do that logically at
our service layers
to ensure that the same
changes that you apply
are systematically applied
across all of your projects,
across all of your applications.
That will make sure that
you have the ability
to sort of multiply your effort.
And we think about this
stuff in a lot of ways.
When I've done operations,
I got really frustrated
that I wasn't Superman.
That I couldn't stay up 24
hours a day, seven days a week.
And that I wasn't able to
move at the speed of sound
from where my desk
was over to the colo,
and then back to my desk,
and then back to the colo,
and back to the desk.
I needed laser beams
to be able to adjust.
We think the public cloud gives
operators an incredible set
of new superpowers.
My favorite would be a total
independence from procurement.
How many folks have a
clear buy in from somebody
to buy the machine?
You've got a clear
need for the machine.
You know exactly the
spec of the machine.
You've got a vendor that's
going to sell you the machine.
You got the form all
filled out for the machine.
And then it'll
totally be shipped
here in like three weeks, but
no it's actually four weeks.
And no, no, they've lost it at
the dock, and it's seven weeks.
All of that stuff
is just deleted
when you have a
provider that is buying
a fifth of the computers
that are manufactured.
We have leftovers.
I swearsies.
So that extra
capacity allows you
to react to your stakeholders
much more nimbly.
They say, I need a build
box this afternoon.
And you say, how about
36 seconds from now?
Because that's the TP 99
launch rate on VMs today.
Don't even launch a form.
Forget that.
It's one rest call.
So put a little wrapper on it.
Put a snazzy, green
button on a web page.
Hand it to him.
Let them off to the
page, smash the button,
they have their own dem box.
Get out of my hair.
I have real work to do.
That kind of change in the
operational model where
your partnership with a
couple of those developers
may be building up a
little bit of the tooling,
building up a little bit of
the access instrumentation,
can really shave off the
un-unique, un-differentiated
work of some of the
base operations.
So again-- superpowers, right?
Environment can get a
zillion times bigger.
And then when
you're done with it,
it can go away and
go away perfectly.
I spent so many hours just
cleaning up network cable
trash on the bottom of my cage.
Just cleanup, just
deleting all of your stuff,
just throwing out
all the mess, getting
rid of the cardboard box and
getting rid of all the stuff.
You don't have any
of that with us.
You're able to just
shrink down to zero
by saying I don't like this
project anymore I'm closing it.
Now it's gone.
You want another one
back that same way,
you can use a deployment
manager template
to stand up that whole
infrastructure over again
from scratch.
You need three copies
of it this afternoon.
Stab, stab, stab.
Deployment manager will deploy
three copies of that rapidly.
You also give yourself
some op superpowers
around your interaction
with developers.
So I take sort of
personal umbrage
at the concept of DevOps.
I've worked at places that
were the inventors of the term,
and I've seen it morph and
become a different thing
every other afternoon.
DevOps now gets just sort
of stuffed into the bucket
that operations is, and
I think that's unfair.
There's a very separate
practice there.
Google's written
quite a lot about.
We call it on our side, SRE.
And a big part of
that practice is
being able to not only build
systems designed not to break,
but enable systems that fix
themselves when they're broken
because they're going to break.
And so a lot of the work
around instrumenting
for easy rollback, easy deploy
and retract, AB testing,
subdivision of different patch
releases into the application,
all that stuff, there's quite a
lot of tooling on Google Cloud
to enable that.
So we expect that
you already have
most of these building
blocks, that they're not
particularly new.
You probably have
virtual machines.
You probably have some kind
of clustered storage system.
You probably have
relational databases,
NoSQL databases of some kind.
How many folks have
incredible nights
of fun staying up super late
maintaining those SQL clusters?
Yes, you love it.
You have a great time.
See?
There were very few hands
there and lots of tears
in the back of the room.
So those jobs are
particularly painful
because the
applications that you're
managing, while they hold the
crown jewels of your business,
in most cases, the
real core data that
powers your applications.
Those applications
are new, very new.
And they're built in the
open, which is awesome.
We are super huge
supporters of open source.
We've given a lot of technology,
particularly for data
storage and data management
to the open source.
But when I talk to operators
what I hear from them
is I want something that
is absolutely war tested.
I want something that's run
hundreds of times bigger
than me.
I want to know for
certain that it operates.
So you heard Eric
describe Spanner.
Spanner is the relational store
that sits behind every Google
service.
It operates at hundreds
of millions of operations
a second in aggregate
across it's zillions
of back-end systems.
And it is globally
transactionally consistent.
It scales as wide
as you want to go.
And you don't have to mess
with figuring out your sharding
structure, or figuring
out how you're
going to do
re-indexes under load,
or load balancing between
read and write levels.
All that stuff's deleted.
That kind of battle
tested infrastructure,
Spanner is a single example, but
is present across Google Cloud
platform's products.
So Datastore is the
data store that--
Datastore is the data store--
Datastore is the
system that they
talked about during the
keynote about Pokemon Go.
That's where they're writing
50 times as many transactions
as other environments
totally unnotified.
Anybody have 50 times
as many computers
as you currently own laying
around but not using them?
And just sort of
keeping them for fun?
No?
OK.
Cool.
I was just double checking.
That availability
of skilled resources
is just very powerful.
That said, we're hoping that
not everything requires change.
So it's my experience that
a really substantial number
of the tools-- the
monitoring, metering,
management applications,
automatic deployment, CICD,
the kinds of applications that
you've built on top of public
data center--
those are already compatible.
We've built and done a lot of
work in our development effort
to ensure that your systems of
record are already compatible
with us.
We've done work with being
able to do monitoring systems
and visualization systems,
Graphite, Influx, Grafana,
all of these tools
plug-in to our services
without any kind of big pain.
We have some first
party stuff for this,
and we think that they
are good products.
But Google's commitment
to open ensures
that we'll continue to make
our applications permeable,
transparent to the
kinds of monitoring
and metering that you
want to be able to apply.
And that means that a lot of
the run books and the sort
of basic approaches that you're
using to operations management
still work today.
And this partnering spans all
of the different components
of the stack.
We're really excited about
what that allows folks to do.
So another example
of the stuff that's
really good-- how many folks
have used Datadog before?
I like it.
Stand up, turn around, wave.
He's from Datadog.
It works really good.
So those kinds of tools,
they work very powerfully
in private environments.
But I think they also get
a couple of superpowers
by being present
in public cloud.
And our value
proposition to you is
to be able to use the same
panes of glass, the same views
that you're used to seeing
in your own environments
on our environment.
And that adds a lot
of value from what
I've seen in reducing the
risk of that transition.
Making it so that it's just
more straightforward to see
a comparison of the two moving.
And so that's like probably
the very first operations best
practice that I'd describe.
Because our systems
are inexpensive,
because we give
them to you for free
for $300 for the
first several months,
because we're in the middle of
making them cheaper every day,
you really should be able to
take at least some component
of your application and have
it run on us in a way that
seems familiar to you.
Not just-- I can turn it
on, but turn it on and hang
the full spectrum of
your current management
and operations tooling
around that application.
I will tell you this
was my experience--
individual single computers are
very reliable building blocks
today.
They do things
like you'd expect.
Any time you move past the
behavior of a piece of software
on a single computer, and you
have more than one computer,
all of a sudden those building
blocks become substantially
unreliable and crappy.
So I'd be really interested--
and you can feel free to
reach out to me personally
after this talk or any
point in the future.
This is a big part of
our commitment to being
available to our customers.
I'd be really interested to hear
as you do those tests what's
the reliability, the
consistency of bandwidth,
the consistency of
network latency,
the consistency of access to
disk and disk performance,
the consistency of access
to remote storage systems,
in comparison to the private
environments that you deploy.
Even environments that are
designed very purpose built,
very single tenant,
very monolithic
around an individual
application,
Google has so radically
over provisioned some
of these basic resources that
they can feel really, really
reliable, and really, really
consistent in comparison
to even your environments that
are private and dedicated,
and certainly in comparison
to other public cloud
environments.
That's at least what
we measure today.
So what are those steps?
How would you do that, right?
We see this happen
in two halves.
So the first is finding
stuff that's a little nasty,
The Brownfield.
Maybe you're not
really in the middle
of considering that the core,
beating heart of the business.
It's the second and
third tier applications
that are more work from
an operations standpoint
than they probably
deserve to be.
Those kinds of applications you
can earn immediate time savings
by having them run
in the environment
where your operations
overhead is lower.
So they can be a very important
step in bringing applications
into a public environment.
We think in a lot of cases
that means moving your existing
database software,
not re-platforming
onto our databases.
It means moving your existing
choices around operating system
and file system instead of
replacing those with more
native cloud environments.
We've got partners.
There's a great
booth downstairs.
You can take a look.
CloudEndure will
help you migrate a VM
within a click of a button.
So if you've already got VMs in
VMWare or Zen or anything else,
those kinds of pieces move
over to us very seamlessly
very fast.
The other piece, once
you've taken something
and you have it in
practice on top of us,
you really have an
opportunity to experiment
with our more modern, more
advanced tool systems.
So take something that's running
in MySQL, maybe 5.6 or 5.7
today, unplug that and
plug it into a Spanner
and see what the
behavior differences are.
Observe inside of your code,
like how much DML do you use?
How many inserts and
updates are there?
Is that something
where Spanner's
going to be compatible
for your work,
or is it not going to be a fit?
Take a look at especially
taking advantage
of our network infrastructure.
So anything behind our CDNs,
behind our load balancers,
behind our front-ends,
those have massive latency
and performance improvements,
particularly for web facing,
customer facing
front-end applications.
We have, again, this
enormous network.
There's no reason
you shouldn't be
able to take advantage of it.
And you can do that even with
a single application running
in a single region
or a single zone.
You're still connected to
Google's global front-end.
So this is the button on
the CloudEndure piece.
Certainly importing virtual
machines is important.
I don't want to underestimate
the degree to which most
of us in the operations field
are absolutely feeling pressure
from developers--
I hear it quite a lot--
to move from virtual
machine-based infrastructures
or baking images or these
other kinds of deployment
modalities into
container-based systems.
We are the ones that
built Kubernetes.
We're the ones that built
the Linux C group that
backs all of this
container technology,
all of Google's
infrastructure everywhere,
every application that
you run, including
these virtual machines,
sits inside of a container.
So we have a little experience
operating this stuff.
It really does create a
very substantial performance
and efficiency benefit
for your applications.
If this virtual machine,
because it's gigabytes in size,
takes seconds to load, an
individual container inside
of our application architecture
takes milliseconds,
50, 55 milliseconds.
If you want to see
that in practice,
I think it's the funnest
demo of the whole thing.
You go out to the main
booth, and there's
a thing that looks like one
of those circus whack-a-mole
hammer machines.
You've seen this?
So it's got little holes in
the table and a little hammer,
and you smash the mole.
Each mole is actually a current
running container inside
of a Kubernetes cluster.
And it's one application.
It has nine copies
in the container.
You can't hit the moles fast
enough to bring the app down.
There's a little special
one in the corner
so you can prove to yourself
that in fact the application
goes down because
it kills them all.
But you can't smash
and slay containers
quickly enough for us to
not go, huh, now it's down.
Huh, let's build a new one.
Huh, let's boot it.
Huh, let's launch it.
That all happens
in milliseconds.
Individual keypresses
are tens of milliseconds,
hundreds of milliseconds.
So that transition operationally
for lots of businesses
is creating very real benefits.
Not only from efficiency, right?
You can cram a lot of containers
onto individual machines.
You can load balance
between sets of containers.
That's a pre-built
part of Kubernetes.
But it also ensures really great
benefits from an availability
standpoint.
You have one virtual
machine fail,
and that's running all
of your application.
The application has failed.
But if you've got a
fleet of virtual machines
and your application is
distributed across them
in clusters, it takes
milliseconds to bring back
online inside intra user
event kinds of signals.
It's very powerful stuff.
So we also have a very
rich and very mature
networking structure.
I hear from a lot
of operations folks
that the number one
impediment to their ability
to adopt public cloud is
access to the kinds of network
configuration and
control that they
need to remain compliant
with their business's best
practices.
You already have
super clear run books
that say you will open these
ports and these protocols
to these IP ranges for
applications inside
of these individual VLANs.
Those building blocks
are present on us.
We call them some
different things
because we're
maniacs about naming,
because I think all nerds
are maniacs about naming.
It all started with
writing my guys
name is Attar of Azeroth at the
top of your character sheet.
We're all terrible
about that stuff.
So our network systems--
the advantage that
you have is that it
feels like everything is
behind one giant terabit
a second firewall.
You have only one place to
make these rule changes.
You have only one system to
never have to patch again.
You don't have to do rolling
updates of new hardware
additions or rolling
redistributions of network
structure.
All that stuff is
built in with us.
We have the same
kinds of controls
that you need-- ingress,
egress filtration,
cross project networking
now is making it
so that you can build
isolated projects that
can pass individual channels
of information back and forth
in secured controlled ways.
We have managed VPN.
We have the ability to build
private interconnect to us,
a thing called Google
Cloud Interconnect.
That allows you to
route private linkages,
so you can take MPLS to
any colo provider that's
on our network edge, and
we're on the other side
of the internet.
So we're in most of the edges.
At 77 of the [? ISXI pairing ?]
points in the world,
and that's not a
big number in total.
There's only about 100 of them.
We're actually at
the rest of those,
but there aren't places where
there's leftover colo space.
So you've got to be able to
get into those facilities.
You can also use
new services from us
that ensure that the
connectivity is private.
You can manage your
own keys there.
You have your own control
over the inscription ciphers
that are used.
You really have a very rich
platform for network control
to ensure that your best
practices can be reused.
And our hope and
our expectation is
that over time we can continue
to lower the barrier of entry
there.
We want to make it so
that you can do things
like copying your current
network configuration
and profiles and
running that on us.
So we have a tool
in GitHub right now
if you're running an AWS,
you can copy your firewall
configurations and paste them
on us and they work right.
No fat fingers.
No accidental whoopsies
on the firewall rules.
That kind of simplification
where we're just
trying to think like
operators and think
about reducing the
risk of implementation,
reducing the
challenges associated
with doing this the right way.
That's a big focus for my
team and other teams at Google
as we embrace these
kinds of workloads.
So we also really
think that there's just
a lot of routinized
grunt work that
goes into this kind of thing.
A particular pain
point that I've seen
is being able to comply
with regulatory oversight.
How many folks are stoked
about their next audit?
Note, no hands.
Audit compliance is a monster,
and it's really brutal
if you're the one
that's manually
constructing all of the logs
of the changes that you made.
Or even if you're using
automation to do it,
those become themselves
systems of record
that now you must maintain
and operate, and keep track
of, and make sure
they don't crash,
and don't lose their data,
and backup their data,
and recover those backups.
Because you can't trust backups
if you haven't recovered them.
Don't do that.
So our systems are already
doing all of that built in.
So every functional change that
you make in our infrastructure
is audit logged.
We have a comprehensive
trail of that log.
You're able to produce
copies of that log on demand.
They are stored in GCS storage,
which does not lose objects.
So you don't have to do the
backup work or the maintenance
work.
You need that stuff shared.
That's all available
online right now.
And it's impossible for
one of your employees
or one of the folks
that you manage
to be able to launch something
that doesn't get logged.
How many folks have
had like that one guy
stuff that one extra laptop
in the corner of the back rack
that makes it so
everything works, but it's
on nobody's spreadsheets, and
it's got no anti-virus on it?
This stuff goes
terrible real fast.
In cloud, you can't get in.
There's no backdoor.
There's no extra
spot where I can
stuff the weird toys that I want
to play with on the weekend.
So we've really
made it so that this
is a place where you can exert
a little more control, a little
more oversight and
management to ensure
that your constituency is the
folks that you're managing
for are following the rules.
And for us what we've
seen is that that
makes the biggest impact
in these kinds of security
and compliance pieces.
A big part is just offloading
all of the operations
work associated with achieving
compliance for everything
below the virtual machine.
We're the ones who have to go
through and prove to the PCI
DSS folks that, yep, these
computers are in point of fact
safe to process credit
card transactions on.
And then all you have to
do is the audit controls
of your application above that.
That's just a much smaller
surface area of management.
And if all of a sudden, like,
say today, you work in retail,
and so you're
processing transactions.
But then all of a sudden
one of your sales guys
gets like super smart and starts
to sell a part of your product
into health care--
oops.
You have to be HIPPA
compliant all of a sudden.
Error.
If you built a compliance
regime and a modeling
and a records system for
your operational tooling
that's designed around one
compliance system, and then
all of a sudden you
have to accommodate
another, that can be a huge
retooling and rebuild exercise.
I've helped companies do that.
So with public
cloud you're already
achieving all of the
standards that we've already
signed up for.
So you already are PCI
DSS level 3 certified
for the infrastructure stack.
We've done that now with
dozens, hundreds of businesses.
You can check that
off your list.
You don't ever have
to work on that part.
And the auditors-- they know.
They've gone to other
customers of ours
and they go, oh, this
is the Google Cloud one?
OK.
Marvelous.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
We know that they have
that part handled.
You don't have to re-explain
it the 800th time.
So that can be very powerful
and can be a very big impact.
So I said a bunch of good news--
public cloud sounds super great.
Right?
You're all going to move.
It's going to be awesome.
Everything is going
to be awesome.
The reality is that
it's not all done.
Right now the ratio to sales
from salespeople to engineers
is deeply biased on
the engineering side.
So there is clearly way
more for us left to build.
So what are the things that
are still hard or complex?
What places can you
anticipate that you're
going to have to do a little
extra operations work in order
to be able to accommodate the
challenges of this system?
First off is-- remember
how I said that it was
like super easy to build stuff?
It's super easy to build stuff.
Which means that you're going
to build all sorts of stuff
like super fast, and
it's going to go out
into the reaches
of the inter web.
There will be copies
of your software
that your engineers decided
they wanted one more build box,
but they wanted it in Singapore.
And they want it in
the middle of nowhere.
That can create very
substantial sprawl.
It is easy to delete stuff.
I made that clear.
But I think many
businesses because they're
used to deleting, meaning
de-racking and shoving
in a chipper shredder, that
all of a sudden deletions
are to be carefully done.
If I delete this, maybe
somebody else's thing turns off.
And I don't know where the
sort of isolation layers are,
and maybe I'll just
leave that thing there.
So I certainly
encourage that the more
work you do in programmatic
management, the more work
that you do in automated
deployment development,
that you match that
effort with the effort
to track and use our--
very clear you have great
tagging capabilities,
great reporting and auditing
capability on our side.
You can certainly keep
track of this stuff
and be able to manage it.
But it is an
absolute place where
we see customers have trouble.
It's also super easy to
use these tools when you
have three virtual machines.
You name the first one web.
You name the second one app.
You name the third one DB.
And it's right
there on a screen.
Yeah, my stack is sweet.
And then you have 750 VMs.
It shows the first 10.
And then at the bottom
it has a little box that
says this is page one of 75.
And you go that's
going to be somewhat
daunting to find my little
snazzy web and app and DB.
So these interfaces are
absolutely designed and built
around the experience
of our developers
and our users who are
building a project for them.
They have to be easy to adopt.
They have to be able to use
and easy to sort of build
your own first thing.
And so there are
absolutely places
where rigor around naming,
rigor around structure,
will save you from
interfaces that
are just utterly unassailable.
The other piece is
once you've gotten
to a place where your
application is now really
more than one copy of
an individual layer.
So I have seven web machines,
and I have 18 app machines,
and I got a brazillion
DBM machines.
That summarization is
something that's still not
particularly good on our tools.
Dashboards don't really
summarize that stuff up
very well.
User interfaces don't
summarize that stuff very well.
So you may end up
in a situation where
you end up having to
supplement our views--
building some of
your own reporting
from your own
analysis that reflects
that kind of summarization.
I think we'll continue
to work on that stuff.
I think that's a
challenge for any system.
Does the picture look good when
it's right up against my face?
And does it look good when
I'm zoomed out 1,000 times?
That's the kind of
challenge we're in.
But it's certainly a place
to keep paying attention to.
We also have in our environment,
and you can certainly configure
machines in a way in your
own networks that are widely
spec'd.
So you could have the
worst conceivable case.
You could have a
four socket box.
But then you buy the
cheapest dirtiest xeons
that there are with two
cores a piece or something.
But then you can slap in two
terabytes or something of RAM.
Or you can have these
unbelievable ram
to compute ratios.
We today leave those
relatively narrow--
6 and 1/2 to 1, to 1/5 to 1--
or 1/2 to 1, sorry.
So the narrowness of that,
if you have very extreme ram
to compute ratios,
those can make it
so that you end up
over provisioning
the processing that you need.
In the same way, our network
is bound to the compute
that you consume.
So you may be in an
environment, like say
you're trying to run
Redis or memcached,
where you're really looking at I
want a box with maximum memory,
maximum network.
You might have to bring
a little extra CPU along
on the ride to get our systems
to give you the network
throughput that you need.
Now, we really over
provision network.
We give you two gigabits
a second per core.
So you're going to have
an 8 core VM with 16
gig a second networking.
And that's not like 16 gigs of
theoretical and then real world
you get like 11
and 1/2, and you're
in there sort of trying to do
MTU reconfiguration to figure
it out-- no, it's 16.
You can do the
test all day long.
They work great.
And you can have a
cluster of 100 of them.
They'll all do 16.
It's very, very fast networking.
But if you need
quick networking,
you're going to end up using
at least that eight core
line to get there.
And that's an important measure.
That becomes interesting
as we continue
to add more raw materials
to the virtual machines.
So today you have what
we call custom VMs.
You can adjust how many
cores and how much memory
you need per VM.
You want a 16 core.
No, forget that.
You want an 18 core VM, and
you want 46.25 gigs of RAM.
Awesome.
We will sell you one of those.
We'll charge you for
only what you need.
But you may also
want SSD on there,
and you may also
want GPU on there.
We'll enable-- and it's
totally unique to Google Cloud.
It's one of the things that
I think is most powerful.
We enable you to
individually assign--
I want three 375 gig
slices of SSD on this VM
with 46.25 gigs of RAM.
And I want four slots
of K80 and Nvidia GPU.
That's a monster virtual
machine we just built up.
But because there are sort of
limits in that scalability,
you have to make sure that
the ratios that you're using
fit into what we document
as a best practice.
So that's critical.
This last one is funny-- yes.
You will certainly end up
in relation to the first one
turning things off and
having people squeal.
I can also sort of say that
some of the important places
to pay attention
to beyond this--
we take very
seriously, many of you
may be because you're
here at the conference,
your early customers,
your aggressive customers.
Google follows a very
clear sequenced step
of product releases.
So we do a thing called early
access that gives people access
to applications before
we think they're done.
And that means that they
can crash and burn and die.
And we change them, and they do
all sorts of terrible things.
We have alpha products that
we think of as probably done,
but we're way beyond
being able to set an SLA
or even understand probably what
pricing will look like or be
able to assert any kind of SLA.
So alpha products some of
our customers get access to.
Lots of our customers get
access to beta products.
Those we also typically keep
the price points off of,
and we're not willing
to sign up for an SLA.
But we think they're
in a final state.
We think that your code won't
change when it moves to GA.
We think that we've got
the API code complete.
So most of our customers,
most of our developers,
feel very comfortable
with beta software.
An important sort of
threshold in that, a way
to anticipate the
degree of confidence
that you can have in
beta to GA software,
is to look and see if that's
a product that's been running
in Google for a long time.
So we've put Cloud
Spanner into beta.
Now, Cloud Spanner powers every
one of the systems at Google.
So you have to imagine that it's
not like we're building Spanner
over again.
What we're doing is we're
adding an API layer that
allows us to charge you for it.
And I suspect that the
operations around the API layer
to charge you for it
are nowhere near as
complex as the cesium clocks
in the GPS devices that
are on the racks and
all the crazy software
that it takes to
make Spanner work.
So in our environments, we're
seeing lots of customers
build production systems
on beta services.
That may be
different than you're
used to in other environments.
And so as you're going
through, certainly
interact with your
customer engineer,
get some of the context
from your peers,
reach out to the
broader community
to understand what they're
seeing in performance
and availability for
the services that
are in alpha and certainly
in beta as you move forward.
We are also very aggressive
about moving to GA.
We take GA very seriously.
It's a very different threshold.
We absolutely commit to SLAs
on all products that are in GA.
And so you'll see the top level
of Google's support and service
for those launches.
That's why it's so exciting
to hear that the ML engine
product has now gone GA,
because you can really
start to look at
businesses getting
ready to deploy very, very
massive machine learning
systems on us and to be able
to count on a very clear SLA.
It's also important for folks
that are building environments
designed for availability--
not every SLA is the same.
You should really
look at what happens
when those SLAs get breached.
Same way as you
should always try
to restore your backups
from time to time.
If the penalties associated
with us failing an SLA,
or with our competitors failing
their SLAs, aren't toothy,
aren't violent--
I want to make
sure that you feel
like your needs are managed
and your needs are satisfied.
Having a contractual
relationship
with a provider that really
binds us to shared fate,
to shared responsibility
over ensuring
that you're successful, I
think that's a critical part.
We've turned that from
a contractual thing,
and now we're actually
doing it in practice.
So one of my sister teams,
Customer Reliability
Engineering, they'll come out.
And our practice with
you is once you've
gone through what we call
a product reliability
review, a PRR, we actually
go through your application
and say, nope,
that's super lame.
You shouldn't run it that way.
And that's super broken.
You shouldn't do that.
That's going to be difficult
for you to maintain.
If you pass the same checklist
that Google applications pass,
then we will share
pagers with you.
We'll take an SLA
for your app, which
is a pretty incredible thing.
There are a couple of
presentations about CRE
I certainly recommend
for the operations
folks to take a
look at that stuff,
because it's really a totally
different level of commitment
from a cloud provider to
folks running applications
on top of us.
So a simple closing haiku--
I think you can probably
move to the cloud,
it's going to be
easier than you think,
it's going to be super groovy.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]